citing security concerns during the
shutdown nancy pelosi has asked donald
trump
to give his state of the union in
writing trump's response
canceling her trip to brussels right
before takeoff
it's hilarious in the letter he said he
was sorry to inform her
that he's canceling the trip no no he
wasn't sorry not at all
he basically stole her lunch money and
then he ate her lunch
still trump should accept her offer and
send the address in writing
a sheet with just two words bye-bye
then hold a giant event in the middle of
america after all the people elected
trump not washington d.c
nancy and the dems can take shelter
under their desks and watch it all on
ipads
and trump can cite his achievements tell
some jokes just so the press has a
reason to burn their hair
broadcast it on youtube the media will
cover it in highly flammable fact checks
it'll be the first people's state of the
union if the media doesn't show it
then we know it's personal and political
for this is historical
and hysterical because what do the dems
do then do they not respond when he does
it anyway
at a better place with better looking
people with music prizes farm animals
and
face painting and almost no carbon
footprint think about that
do they hold a response with the same
cardboard cutouts from before
man nancy just offered trump an amazing
opportunity
it gets him out of a really dull speech
and it gets the five
out of going to dc a place with
overpriced boos
incompetent politicians and substandard
food
which really is the whole point of this
monologue
all right originally we're going to talk
about the state of the union but we've
got to talk about this letter
which is fantastic dear madam speaker
due to the shutdown i'm sorry to inform
you i'm sorry to inform you
that your trip to brussels egypt and
afghanistan has been postponed
we will reschedule this seven-day
excursion when the shutdown is over
oh jeez this obviously
if you would like to make your journey
by flying commercial that would
certainly be your prerogative
dana okay some might say this is
childish or
i think juan thinks this is childish i
think it's childishly
awesome you just stole my notes
so this uh story broke during the two
o'clock hour and i
had john roberts on peter ducey and we
find out that not only
is he canceling the trip yeah but the
trip is supposed to leave in 30 minutes
yes so they're on the bus on the air
force bus with the cup hill please ready
to go
she already took her ambien oh no never
do that
never take your ambien until you're on
the runway about to take you fall asleep
if it gets delayed right and then you
then you could get in trouble
and all the things so um
i knew something was going to happen
today because it was like just the
timing i
also feel like because the president was
silent yesterday in response to her
suggestion that he rescheduled the state
of the union because of security but now
it's actually just because of the
shutdown and her leverage
that they waited until that 30 minutes
before that bus was supposed to leave in
order to do it and it
is kind of like a reality tv show so i
think oh well tit for tat
there i understand the thing about their
security concerns she was going to
afghanistan
but here's the thing what congressional
delegation thinks it's a good idea
to leave town when the shutdown is
entering its fifth week
i think he actually just saved them some
major embarrassment i think they're both
doing each other a favor but one i want
to get to you because i know that you
thought it was idiotic or childish
but it's see what makes us laugh should
also
bring you pleasure it's not funny a
little bit you mean should be happy that
i'm happy
i'm glad look i'm entertained i love
this show i think it's great
you know let's make fun of everybody but
at some point you got to say you know i
wasn't gary cohn the economic advisor to
trump said today he doesn't understand
where this is going
it's bad for the economy we see the
economy that's true being damaged
there's real consequence so yeah i love
a laugh too i got no problems but i i
will say this
to dana's point i think it was president
trump who actually went overseas to a
war zone
during the shutdown yeah
that was when pollution so they couldn't
have actually had another
in other words trump is being totally
hypocritical and
colliding in it by saying oh i'd like
you to be here so you can negotiate well
wait a second didn't he leave town
he wasn't in town why it doesn't matter
because he was gone hawaii
he was gone jesse but he was gone so i
mean to me
what you see today is oh trump's now
saying let's bring back some diplomats
oh okay yesterday was let's bring back
some irs agents
he is so on the defensive so losing this
fight
right now that he is trying to lessen
the impact
of the shutdown on the american people
but he delights
in boorish behavior skewering nancy
pelosi and making himself look
and i use greg's word childish jesse i
gotta i want to just shift a little bit
to the offer that pelosi is giving
because i believe he should accept the
offer do it in writing
and hold this uh rally but you disagree
with me yeah i'm pro-state of the union
i want to see the president blast the
democrats
and have nancy sit next to pence and
squirm without being able to respond
and then maybe if she wants to she can
respond with crying chuck at
one podium afterwards and get hammered
because i like the pageantry of it and
usually the presidents get a little bit
of that you want to go to dc
just admit it's just in
yeah i would never stay there right the
company's paying for it it would be a
conflict of interest
and you know i'm always on the up and up
with these things
also remember the last time the
democrats just sat on their hands
and they said the african-american
hispanic american unemployment
was at record unemployment at record
lows so there's there's political
wins to be had for the president at the
state of the union
and she does doesn't want the president
to have the opportunity
to go make the case for the american
people but what he did today was pure
savage
nancy pelosi is petty but no one is more
petty than donald trump
she went low he went lower yes and my
favorite line is you can fly commercial
like jet blue
flies to afghanistan please i mean she's
been in hawaii one her crew is in puerto
rico
she hasn't been at the white house for a
week and then she's going to brussels
and afghanistan for another week
she doesn't want to end the shutdown she
likes it she thinks she's scoring points
let me ask you something
i know you're like trump but was that an
endorsement of trump to say he's going
lower than
lower than low i think jamesmanship and
one you can't say that what pelosi did
the other day with the state of the
union
was a great power play and this is
childhood i think it was a great problem
everybody on the left let me get the
documentary here's what i said you know
what the government's broken the
government's not functioning and to
stand up there and pretend like
everything is normal
is what jesse is saying
trump and pelosi are made for each other
right so one goes one way one goes the
other way whatever
the bottom line is as a parent it
reminds me of a lot of the staff
sapphire household or just a bad
telenovela the way that this is playing
out
and unfortunately we can laugh at it
it's funny
but it's not funny because these are
actually supposed to be the adults of
our country
and so whether we he goes to the state
of the union okay it's going to be the
same thing it's a political
episode we're going to see the democrats
maybe squirm a little bit it's going to
be a democrat bashing session
nothing's actually going to come out of
it and you know nancy pelosi
spokesperson her she they came out and
said that
the purpose of her trip was to express
appreciation thanks to our men and women
of service you know how she can do
that by staying here and getting getting
the government back and start playing
the coast guard
because they're not getting paid and
they're also men and women in uniform i
do wonder a little bit about this
because you know um
i used to when i was at the white house
i would do this thing called a sister
test
so i'd call my sister and say like what
do you think about this and if she said
never heard of it i'm like oh thank god
we're all right
but today she said something to me she
sent me a text and she was like
both of them could they just get it
together right something like that and i
wonder if that's more of the
of course we can laugh for a moment it
is like really funny but there are
consequences for people that are
rand paul made a suggestion do we want
to play that tape or do we have time
or should i just summarize it nobody's
talking to me
go yeah i think that's a real affront to
the american people and what i would
suggest
is that senator mcconnell's in charge of
the senate let's host it in the senate
if she this will be the first time in
history
that the house would deny a president
the forum of speaking
if she's going to do that let's hold it
in a second i do not like this idea
this is so it's just boring i think it's
even more boring it's even more boring
don't host it you want to see a rally in
like billings montana
no marilyn i want to get a few days in
the sun
already you know he had a speech already
in the oval office did it move
anything did it change anything this is
the state of the union address it is a
unifying thing for the country we have
very few
traditions do you think it'll be
unifying i think he'll stand up there
and just tell more distortions
and lies and misrepresent but i'm also
okay with it going back to
a written thing that's the way that was
the original intent by the way
they're having a super bowl you need a
lot of security for that too okay